so I currently have a 3-hour cinematic
law video for the entirety of armored
Core 6 in the works and it's almost
ready for release but until then I think
secrets are always a good way to fill
the time so number one I don't know if
anyone asked but yes you can get stepped
on by The
Strider in new game Plus+ you're given
the option to escort the thing but
Institute mechs show up and destroy it
before you get the chance so if you
really want to escort The Strider just
avoid climbing it in the original
Mission and after a really really long
time it will walk out of bounds the
target has left the combat
zone 621 you failed the mission if you
thought that Walter sounded disappointed
there wait until you hear these next
lines from all mind if you refuse to
compete in the arena until your third
playthrough she says this when you
complete rank D it appears the simulator
struggled to hold your interest but
perhaps your self-possession is what is
needed to achieve great things we will
learn from your example of course this
means doing the entire game without any
OS tuning upgrades which is no mean feat
we admire the fortitude needed to
maintain self-discipline under the
circumstances this has been a fruitful
exercise spoiler warning but if you
completed the third ending you'll know
that allm mind is kind of a rogue AI
desperate to achieve Coral release to
the point where she attempts to kill you
at the end of the game so she gets
extremely confused if you assist with
her integration program after knowing
full well what she is your assistance
with the program is
appreciated but why now do you think do
you think that the release project May
yet succeed one day she truly loses her
mind when 621 you know this God killer
of a pilot only decides to complete her
training exercises at the very end of
their journey is this correct you never
achieved certification until now but how
did you what were you
thinking this is all very confusing but
thank you for participating before I go
on I want to quickly shout out displate
the sponsor of this video they're
currently hosting a Black Friday sale
and the discounts shown on screen are
the highest they've ever had so if
you've been putting off getting some
highquality prints fuel walls now's kind
of the best time I have a ton of
fromsoft inspired ones that I think you
might like there's the painted world
filled with four worlds inspired by Dark
Souls bloodborne Seco and Demon Souls
there's Raven's return there's firee
keeper Apprentice Guardian Of Moonlight
conver
and now for the first time there's
convergence 3D which reimagines the
previous print in a more
three-dimensional style there's a ton of
little secrets hidden in there as always
and I hope it leads those that buy it to
come back and find more so if you're
interested links in the description but
for now back to the video so in armad
core 4 the briefings looked like this
and recently data Miner zulli the witch
found this shot from an unused armored
Core 6 cutscene which probably used this
briefing style as a sort of placeholder
interestingly it's revealed here that
the bous Mt was called a communist Mt at
least for a little while internally it
is balum giving this briefing so I guess
it kind of fits that they'd label the
rlf as Communists one question I came
across in my comments was someone asking
why Rusty was ranked ninth in the arena
simulator when canonically you know he's
one of the most Adept pilots in the game
well to answer that Rusty is an
undercover agent for the rlf and it's
possible he doesn't want to attract too
much attention or to be seen as a
Potential Threat until the time is right
compare his motives to the top ranking
Arena pilot who's Freud who is just
obsessed with his AC's performance Freud
lives for the fight so it makes sense
that he would rank up higher in the
arena even if Rusty could canonically
wipe the floor with him alternatively
Rusty being ninth could also be a call
back to Armed core 4's white glint who
is this legendary next AC that was also
ranked ninth in the arena despite being
and I quote considerably more powerful
than its rank suggests but even Rusty is
nothing compared to 621 who in New Game
Plus at least is capable of killing the
Juggernaut boss so fast that Rusty
doesn't even get a chance to fly away
this results in unique dialogue from
Rusty since he's still here at the end
of the battle so that's how a Hound
fights I'll take care of mopping up the
remaining
hostiles with luck maybe we'll meet
again so I've heard that when Rusty
calls 621 buddy he's perhaps more
accurately calling them battle buddy or
comrade which are more literal
translations of the Japanese word that's
used I've heard people say that the word
buddy sounds a lot more natural in
Japanese than it does in English and I
can sort of see that because buddy
always sounded a bit condescending to me
but I also get why the localization
chose that word as I agree that it
sounds better than battle buddy or
comrade another thing that a few people
have noted is that Rusty and Raven
friendship might actually be reflected
in nature as well Ravens are caran birds
relying on the leftover meat of other
animals to feed so in many cases
logically Ravens have been observed at
wolf kill sites but what scientists
noted was strange was that the Wolves
didn't chase off the birds despite the
birds consuming a large portion of their
kill Ravens have even been observed
playing with young wolf pups and all of
this and more has led some to believe
that there might be a mutualistic
relationship between the species where
both benefit in some way the Ravens
clearly benefit from finding the Wolves
kills and some speculate that the Ravens
actually help the Wolves find potential
prey as well number 10 you might have
noticed that steel Hayes orus the the AC
that Rusty eventually Pilots it looks a
bit different to other ACS and I think
this might be by Design After All Steel
Haze or Tous represents a sort of
advanced arabus prototype and
canonically it's this huge leap forward
in Tech that the rlf desperately need
and I've seen a lot of people commenting
that this Alba AC looks a lot more
Gundam than anything else in the game
and there on to something there because
ota's design can be credited to takayuki
Yan a popular Mech designer and former
employee of from software also known for
Designing many Gundam units I've seen
comments that they really nailed the
heroic look of this Mech and I agree
that heroic look really suits
considering what this Mech means to
Rusty and the rlf number 11 events on
Rubicon are brought about out by the
original Raven and Branch who leak the
fact that Coral is present here to the
corporations fittingly Raven's AC is
called Nightfall I feel like that sort
of represents the darkness that is
falling over Rubicon as the game begins
to contrast with this though Rusty's AC
is steel hay otus and the word otus is
Latin for Sunrise a reference to Rusty's
desire to usher in a new dawn for
Rubicon and fittingly Nightfall appears
at the start of the game and sunrise
appears at the end the word Sunrise is
also referenced in Rusty's theme which
plays when you defeat him at top the
xylm I always found this moment so sad
as he finally achieves his goal to Pilot
this new AC but he's forced to Pilot it
against you instead of arabus the
relevant lyrics are as
follows
[Music]
of all the characters in the game Rusty
is definitely the most anime so anime
that he's coded to assault boost into
you at the start of your fight the game
wants you to have this epic Clash and
this is so hardcode Ed that even if you
assault boost back at him he won't break
away to avoid you or anything the
coolest part of Raven AC is its visor
the shade eye which is actually a
modified version of the finder eye that
621 has equipped at the start of the
game the way the visor drops on this is
so cool but did you know it actually
does this in game as well the visor will
drop whenever you lock onto enemies and
I think it's the only headpiece with
this Behavior what's more you can
actually paint this part of the
headpiece if you want even more style
when it drops when it comes to part
names in ac6 they can seem pretty random
but there's actually a logic to pretty
much all of them in fact entire
categories of parts in this game
actually have themes for example as
discovered by user redpool on Reddit
Parts by bous are named after the 10
renowned disciples of matsuo Basho a
famous Haiku poet of the Edo period
balam's Parts feature the surnames of
famous entomologists whose research
relates to the study of insects dang's
parts are named after ancient Chinese
constellations ELO's parts are Spanish
words like the viento which means wind
and trino which means Thunder melanites
parts are rock and metal references the
RIS parts are often animal body parts
and astronomy terms I'll also add that a
lot of rri machines are named after
plants like the helianthus sunflower and
the nepenthes pitcher plant and finally
Schneider's parts are bird names in
German like the knock rer being named
after the black crowned night heron this
also suits their tendency to design
aerodynamic Parts speaking speaking of
references though there's nothing
greater than the KRV multi- energy rifle
which is a reference to the carawa from
past games this thing has three stages
of charging and when it hits its final
stage it starts to look quite similar to
the carasa of the past and you should
try this thing out because it recently
got a total ammo buff in the recent
patch so I feel like it's finally viable
for longer missions now try du wielding
this with the ve 46a arms and let me
know if that's any good and speaking of
a patch that's the name of patches in
the armed Core Series or the closest
thing to him anyway and he made his
debut as patch the good luck in armored
Core for Answer and as noted by zulie
the witch Patch's English voice actor
actually returns in armed cor 6 as none
other than Handler Walter so I wonder if
Handler Walter asked 621 to jump off a
cliff would they do it Walter was a
child at Institute City back before the
fires of Ibis where he eventually came
under the guardianship of Professor
nagai of the Rubicon Research Institute
here they came up with all kinds of tech
including AC parts some of which appear
to be named after members of The
Institute the most obviously named
pieces have the abbreviation ngi on the
them which surely abbreviates the name
of Professor Nagi but then some parts
also have wlt on them which logically
would be an abbreviation of Walter who
was also present but there's other
three-letter
abbreviations cell Hal and soul which
all refer to the ibus craft and of these
Hal is the only one that consists of AC
parts making it somewhat similar to two
ngi and wlt parts and since ngi and wlt
were probably named after people perhaps
it's possible that Hal was as well if I
had to guess I think Hal might have been
Walter's father because according to
nagai's logs Walter's father was
assistant number one to Professor Nagi
and they're the only major character in
these logs that we never get a name for
Coral weapons like the WL T 101 and the
ng6 are very unique in armored cor 6 in
that they deal a type of damage that
there are no defenses for not kinetic
energy or explosive this is particularly
important information in PvP and these
weapons might do more damage there than
their stat screens imply but
interestingly you don't need to wield
Coral Weaponry to take advantage of the
coral though all you need is a coral
generator in addition to turning your
boosters red coral generators also
affect your assault armor your pulse
armor and your pulse protection effects
but this isn't just a color change
because your assault armor will now deal
Coral damage meaning it does a
significant amount more than regular
assault armor will what's more pulse
armor and pulse protection also get a
significant boost to their effectiveness
making any build that can support a
coral generator better than you might
expect shout out to Rubicon dogs for
detailing this information and more in a
video link in the description pulse
armor is my favorite extension and the
reason why actually has nothing to do
with the amount of armor you get instead
it's my favorite because whenever you
activate it it immediately cancels out
all of your builtup impact and I love
how this allows you to interact with
your stagger bar in a sense it's a
really good highlevel gameplay Habit to
get into you'll notice a lot of AC's in
the arena make use of this mechanic as
well and it's no surprise that these are
often some of the hardest fights combine
this technique with any heavy build that
is spec to absorb a lot of impact and
you'll become borderline unstaggered in
most encounters speaking of pulse
Shields did you know that pulse effects
might have previously been gold instead
of light blue as pointed out by user
keeper utx on Reddit early leaked
screenshots of armed core 6 revealed
gold player shields in many of the shots
this user also points out that the logo
for takawa harmonics is golden and
takawa harmonics are the designers of
the pulse guns in the game which
themselves have golden dishes on them so
I think this golden color would have fit
perfectly I wonder why they changed it
number 22 one of my favorite visual
effects in this game are the core
cooling animations that play out
whenever you activate an extension every
single one of these is different
depending on the core part that you have
equipped here's a quick Showcase of some
of the best
ones my favorite is the animation of
this one though I love the spinning orbs
on the side number 23 one habit I have
when I'm researching the law on new from
games is to look over the song list
which often have little law tidbits in
them in Elden ring for example the song
list revealed that marget is an omen
illusion giving us an official term for
the mirror images that Omen in the game
have and in armed core 6 as well some
songs do reveal a bit more flavor about
the game for example the song that plays
when you're in the garage is called
stowaway which presumably references the
garage unit you're stowed away in as a
passenger and we never get direct
confirmation of this but I like to
imagine that this garage is pretty
mobile since you access it across many
different continents and that also
supports that sort of stowaway feeling
as it travels around the world uh the
song that plays when you confront and
surprise the Testa AC pilot is called a
fight or flight and it makes you realize
that it's actually pretty admirable that
the tester AC pilot returns fire here
here rather than just running away next
the song that plays during the mission
to investigate bouse arsenal number two
is named pulling strings perhaps
referencing how the rlf is using you to
figure out what's really going on here
or it could be referencing all mind who
is sort of pulling strings behind the
scenes especially at the bouse Arsenal
and when you first enter Institute City
the song that plays is called make
things right and after all in this
decimated City you're seeing what
burning the coral and making things
right looks like to Walter and Carla for
the first time speaking of which song 44
is the man who passed the torch and the
man in question is presumably Walter
he's the one who wanted you to take on
his legacy and burn the coral and him
being the man who passed the torch is so
poet IC with that context in previous
armed core games there were way more
extension parts and shoulder parts to
choose from back then you could equip
energy Shields bomb launchers heat sinks
extra missiles extra boosters emergency
energy refills radar jamming and even
decoys or flares to draw enemy fire away
from you and I remember thinking that
flares or anti-missile systems would be
really useful in ac6 looking at you BTUs
so imagine my surprise when I realize
that flares actually are in the game you
just can't use them it's so easy to miss
but some LC's from the PCA actually do
emit flares which will immediately drag
your missiles from their intended target
so this gives me faith that will at
least see flares added to the game in
DLC or something eventually the tech is
clearly there and it would be great to
have more customization choices like
there were in previous games I used to
love how much utility and flavor these
extra parts and extensions gave to your
Mech the hc's and LCS from the PCA in
general just have a bunch of cooltech
that would be great to use on an AC like
they even have these solid Shields from
previous games which back then wouldn't
impact your energy meter at all when you
absorbed damage so why can't I equip
these and when the pca's forces get
assimilated by arabus this unit gets an
energy Shield which can have its energy
focused to a fine point turning the
shield into a spear even their energy
Shields become cooler than ours one
thing you should experiment with are
assault boosted quick turns which not a
lot of people know about if you have
your quick turn unlocked in the OS
tuning menu you can actually hold that
button while assault boosting to unlock
90° turns while maintaining your assault
boost making navigation just a tiny bit
easier when I was making my build video
one thing I learned was that the recoil
stat is sometimes even more important
than the firearm specialization stat
because it doesn't matter how fast you
can track enemies if you don't have the
recoil control to stay on target
especially when it comes to fast firing
weapons what I didn't know was that the
recoil of a weapon on one arm can affect
the recoil of the weapon on the other
arm so you might look at your shotguns
High recoil stat and figure it doesn't
matter at all because shotguns fire so
slowly but if you couple a shotgun with
another arm weapon that does get
affected by recoil then the shotgun
bursts on one arm will cause your other
weapon to be wildly inaccurate it's just
something to keep in mind that's why I
tend to dual wield two types of the same
weapon most of the time dual wielding
two of the same weapon also makes it
easier to keep track of which weapons
you're using uh this is the strategy I
used when I was trying to beat bolteus
without taking a hit since I needed to
focus so much more on avoidance rather
than damage and in two of these attempts
I discovered an extremely rare
circumstance where B would initiate
Phase 2 without activating salt armor
now usually this happens strictly at
half Health but in a couple of cases it
glitched out and suddenly started using
the flamethrower and machine gun which
are Phase 2 weapons without any warning
not that I was complaining since this
was actually good for my no hit run but
it meant that I was completely caught
off guard when it did assault armor
later here doing damage to me and ending
this attempt so close the word bolteus
actually refers to an ancient Roman
sword belt or the passages between teers
of seats in a Roman Amphitheater both of
these things call to mind the circular
missile belts of BTUs making it such a
great name it's also consistent with the
Antiquated naming scheme of many other
PCA Mech like the Ecto craft which
referen Greek outrunners that would
fight a head of the main army or the PCA
cact which is named after soldiers and
horses who wore caats suits of armor
that covered their entire body secret 30
at the start of operation wall Climer
there's something firing at you from up
on high its projectile is by far the
most dangerous thing as you approach but
did you know that it's actually the
Juggernaut boss firing at you from the
top of the wall 31 one so it's been a
while and there's now a decent selection
of armored Core 6 mods over on the Nexus
my favorite one has to be this The Next
Movement regulation which aims to make
your AC pilot a lot more like the next
did from the fourth generation of
armored Core with this installed flying
will require less energy movement will
be faster and you can chain quick boosts
together bringing back that Whiplash
movement of the fourth gem to your
fights if you're looking for a way to
spice up your next playthrough this
might be a fun mod to try out number 32
back before armed core 6 was released
there was an exclusive event in Japan
where people could line up and actually
play a demo build of the game lucky
players were able to select from one of
three preset builds which fromsoft
themselves only just shared with us here
are their download codes back back for
the demo players had 15 minutes with
these builds to take on the mission to
infiltrate the grid and to take out
rammy and the smart cleaner apparently
the energy at this event was insane and
people who managed to play the game for
the crowd often achieved meme status for
example one man was given the title The
Seco of Hiroshima for clearing the demo
with an injured arm I love it at that
Japanese demo a lot of people loved ry's
signature scream about mad stomp and in
the full version of the game there's
actually another character that became
quite popular among the Japanese player
base and that's honest brute I think he
was popular because his Japanese
dialogue actually comes across a bit
differently he actually sings his quick
slow quick quick slow tune in English
not Japanese as you'd
expect
quick quick
SL SL SL quick SL but in contrast
there's another character whose dialogue
I feel is objectively better in the
English than the Japanese so as you may
know if you stop attacking swinburn then
you get the opportunity to spare his
life but if you do that you'll incurve
the wrath of Roku monsen an elite
assassin associated with the rlf who
canonically loves Japan and Japanese
culture death and dishonor such as the
oath bregger due pay the
Sonu according to his bio he has a
particular interest in ninjas and Kabuki
and is well-versed in long lost
classical theater but one amazing
decision the English localization team
made is that they decided to have him
speak entirely in Haiku the scoundrel's
profits coins slipping through cold
fingers feed rubicon's soil if you don't
know a haiku is a Japanese form of
poetry consisting of short un rymed
lines delivered in a thre line format
with each line consisting of five
syllables then seven then five syllables
again he breaker treachery benefits
none cor will take
you imagine the focus it takes to
compose Haiku while fighting at these
speeds godamn the name Roku monen also
has a lot of meaning as it pertains to
this character Roku means six mon is the
ancient currency unit and Sen is coin
and when rokum monsen says pay the Sonu
T he's referring to a Japanese myth that
a toll of six mon must be paid before a
soul can cross the sansu river to the
afterlife an invaluable resource for ac6
Content has been gray caliber who has
been compiling all cut and Alternate
dialogue from characters over on their
YouTube channel in one video they note
the differences in how P treats you
after you escape from re-education here
their plan is initially to capture you
alive Raven the independent mercenary
subject to re-education is on the
run I have direct orders from V2
snail capture Raven and send the
fugitive to the factory this
time but as you continue to evade
capture things start to escalate and
eventually snail decides to have you
killed this is V6 P I've received orders
from V2 snail
if the target resists you are authorized
to use lethal Force but if you
previously took the mission to Ambush
The Vespers destroying P's AC and then
killing Hawkins Peter will remember that
and he will defy snail to have you
killed Instead This is V5 P I'm
exercising my authority to revise your
orders you are authorized to use lethal
Force The Fugitive survival is not
Mission
critical he probably also feels more
confident exercising his authority here
because if you took the mission to
Ambush The Vespers then Peter will
naturally be a higher rank in this
Mission because you would have already
killed his Superior V5 Hawkins another
piece of amazing dialogue happens in the
mission to destroy the ice worm where
Michigan chews you out if you neglect to
bring the stun needle launcher the very
thing that this entire plan hinges upon
gun 13 let's see that fancy Gizmo that
aramus paid the big bucks
for what you didn't bring it gun 13 your
ability to ruin my field trips is
uncanny but one of the best dialogue
changes happens if you fly past V2 snail
in this mission to eliminate syala
instead of fighting him
that's V2
snail the man who captured you at
Institute
City it's up to you how you want to deal
with him but the resulting dialogue
doesn't happen in this Mission it
happens in the next one when snail
confronts you while piloting arabus
baltus if you fought him earlier he'll
say that no your crime is that you tried
to kill me kill arabus but if you didn't
fight him he takes takes offense to that
too no your crime is that you ignored me
ignored
arabus you are verman and I will be rid
of you can we just take a moment to
appreciate how many subtle voice changes
they worked into the game and how
seamlessly they all work depending on
these tiny choices that you make one of
the craziest comes from chatty who
actually has different lines of dialogue
that can change based on the level of
access speed that you've unlocked in the
OS tuning menu if you regain access to
the xylm with Max Speed he says this
Chief I
couldn't never learn to laugh but if you
do it slower with your speed less
upgraded he says extra lines
instead I'm sorry
G you gave me
life but in the end I never learned to
laugh so yeah upgrade your access speed
and save yourself that extra bit of
heartbreak so we all know that AC's are
big but how big are the ones in six to
figure this out a lot of people online
have used these as a metric for
comparison standard shipping containers
which are about 2.6 M or 8.5 ft high in
real life and since the average AC
aligns with four of them that would make
the average AC about 10 m or 34 ft tall
but how does this compare to other AC's
in the series in earlier generations of
armored Core the topic of size seems
pretty hotly debated and there are some
inconsistencies in sort of the
comparisons you can make between like
cars and trucks in those games as well
but in AC 4 and 5 there are some good
official sources for size putting an
AC's height at about 5 m for fifth gen
AC's and 10 m for fourth gen next AC's
so long story short AC's in Gen 6 are
about the same size as they were in four
but even though they're about the same
size a fourth gen next AC would still
wipe the floor with a Gen 6 AC from
fires of Rubicon no contest as for what
the biggest structure in ac6 is that
title kind of has to go to the vascular
plant which when fully repaired extends
into space itself there's a great video
on the topic by V limit where he breaks
it down as follows here is the AR tree
and here is the vascular plant if that's
not impressive enough to you that's fine
because I
lied this is the vascular plant so yeah
it's big the fact that arabus repair
this thing in that relatively short
period of time where you're captured is
also extremely impressive number 42 one
of the most iconic elements of armor cor
6 is this the red glint this thing is
everywhere from the very first mission
to the very final moment you cannot stop
seeing it once you know about it I'm not
sure exactly what it's supposed to
represent though I like to think of it
as a sort of signature of the coral a
visual element commonly seen on this
planet that is defined by that Sublime
red substance so a little while ago I
finished s-ranking every Mission and it
was fun I uploaded the entire process on
my second Channel which which you can
check out here I didn't find it too hard
but there were some missions that were
surprisingly difficult but one cool
thing is that renowned Mo the fifth mat
actually made a ranking calculator for
this game which allows you to slide all
of the variables around for every
mission to try and figure out exactly
what repair costs ammo costs and clear
time criteria you need to meet for your
S rank this is an incredible tool if
you're having trouble Link in the
description One mission apparently cut
at some point in development was one
where we would have faced off against
the Watchman a name that allegedly would
have referred to the giant satellite
cannon that shoots you down in the
introduction according to zulie the
witch there's an unused NPC version of
this cannon with an ID that places it
alongside bosses like the HC helicopter
or the sea spider thus its logic IAL
that this thing could have once have
been fought probably in a similar
Fashion To The Strider with platforms
that you would have had to work your way
around zulli also reveals that the
satellite does fire on the xylm as a
piece of background scenery during the
mission to shut down the closure
satellites though of course you can't
interact with it at all but speaking of
laser orbits the PCA should just put a
ton of these little V p60 LT turret
things up in space as a closure system
instead because these things have been
buffed a lot they're now so strong and
so accurate that you can absolutely
decimate any AC dumb enough to fly into
you as long as you have a bit of time to
set them up in advance I mean just look
at this continuing down the list of
things that have been buffed let's talk
about the explosive thrower I really
wanted to include a build with this in
my build video but it just wasn't good
enough at the time but as of patch 1.03
it has better range more ammo and faster
reload time making it consistently hit
anything that comes close to you it also
looks fantastic as a sort of faux shield
for any Gundam build if you're into that
another thing I really wanted to make
work in my build video was the burst
handgun which is perhaps the lightest
weapon in all of ac6 because of this it
works beautifully on a lightweight build
and with the right parts you're able to
exceed 400 boost speed making you so
hard to hit even without dodging it's
really fun my favorite build uses these
with a laser dagger and that's all you
need previously the only problem with
this build was that this handgun didn't
have enough total ammo to complete a lot
of missions but since that's been
recently fixed this build build is now
suddenly able to take on longer missions
and even the Final Bosses as well so
this is a great build to have stored in
your hanger the last few patches have
also been extremely generous to the
Bazookas and grenade launchers which got
nice Buffs across the board especially
noteworthy now are the mes a spread
bazooka which hits consistantly and got
buffed to be way lighter the armored
Core Series has a long history of model
kits based on popular ACS that you can
assemble and I'm hoping they'll make
some for ac6 as well but until then they
have announced this a pre-built figure
of Soul 644 which you find at the end of
the fires of Raven ending this is a
collaboration between 30mm and Bandai in
the robot Spirits line of figures and
apparently they have a good reputation
for Quality figures so if you're looking
to to pick one up I'll try to update the
description with a purchase link as soon
as they're available and speaking of
things being made available to the
public I've always wanted to do that
with my law Maps which are what I use
these days to help me understand all of
the law for my videos so this is the
Mind map we put together for ac6 special
thanks to misspap zard Absa and gray
caliber for their help on this it
features pretty much every single piece
of dialogue from every Mission arranged
chronologically with detailed notes on
every relevant part of the game and with
all of the info laid out for me like
this it's made it so much easier to make
sure I don't miss any details now this
software kind of limits the max amount
of people who can view this at the same
time so right now it's just available
for $5 patrons over on patreon but if
there's enough demand I'll try try to
open it up somehow at the start of this
video I mentioned that I've got a huge
law video in the works and this law map
is part of the reason it's taken so long
to create the entirety of AC 6's story
is in here and I hope having these law
Maps helps other people to dive into
these stories for themselves if they
don't want to just rely on me this video
will be released soon and I hope it does
the game Justice after that it's back to
Elden ring which I'm so extremely
excited for but thanks for watching
check out the displates in the link
below if you haven't already and I'll
see you next
time